- [Mark] All right, Tony, Tony Borges?
- Tony Borges, yes.
- [Mark] Tony, you have a
very interesting project you're doing,
a housing project that involves--
- Yes, we're doing housing for
pre-schools,
commercial
and for residential.
And
10 years ago,
I came up with this system
to build for the homeless
and laid it all out 10 years ago,
had
marketed a little bit
when we were doing the schools
and
it just,
it never came across.
And then I rethought what I was doing,
and I came up with,
I thought a better solution
for what we're doing.
And the solution is to hire
5-10% of the homeless
to build the structures.
And we've been building
these structures since 1980.
We've done it where we've went to islands
and took non-skilled labor to build them.
So we've been doing it forever.
But what I did from the ones that
we did nine years ago,
they were smaller houses.
Now I came out with houses
that would be for the women and kids.
One for the women and women,
the other will be for men and men.
We can make them two story.
They can go on a,
from a one-acre
to a five to ten acre site of land.
They can be also,
the men could be two-story
if we get a tight site.
We're right now,
we're putting the funds together
to start from San Pedro,
to Lancaster to build 12 facilities.
- [Mark] So, these are
homeless communities?
that were homeless
- Homeless community.
Now, to give you an idea
of the homeless community,
if you're familiar with
like a mobile home park,
they're like a mobile home park,
a mini mobile home park,
except their really buildings,
the same buildings we build the schools
the same quality.
- [Mark] So you have a building process?
- Yeah, we have.
- [Mark] The process is very unique.
- Yeah, we've been doing this since 1980.
- [Mark] And tell me about
the process of building it.
- We've been building schools.
There's a company called DSA
or state architects
called DSA.
All this product is built under DSA
requirements like.
So it's all,
all ADA
all handicap,
could be anything that we wanna build
out of this product.
So that's what we're doing.
- [Mark] And there's,
the structures are built
fairly quickly right?
- Yeah.
Well, they're made in a factory
and they take them out to the job site.
That's where we trained the people
to actually put them back together
and then also
erect them and finish
them on the job site.
- [Mark] How many days,
how long does it take to build?
- Once the building gets on the job site,
five days.
- [Mark] Five days to build a
- An average of--
how many square foot house?
- They are 540 feet up to 600 feet.
- [Mark] So small structures, but...
- Well, yeah, but I mean,
they're very high quality.
The nine-foot high ceilings,
we didn't cut any corners.
But these homes are also fire resistant.
There's no wood in them,
but they're just the same buildings
that we've built schools out of.
- [Mark] And you use select
workers from the homeless community?
You would train them?
- Yes!
Yeah, train them, yeah.
At one time,
we had the factory about
25, 30 years ago
in,
in Torrance.
And I moved the factory to Compton
and I couldn't find any workers,
so I'd get the workers--
- [Mark] Because no one
wants to go to Compton.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There was black people there and I go,
that's okay, I've been all over Africa.
I was in Africa in
1959/
with the US government
building water projects
and sewer systems for Africa.
So I've been around working with people,
but when I moved to Compton,
my workers wouldn't go to Compton.
So I would get them from the jail,
they would burst them in from the jail.
And we were at one time building
four houses an hour in the factory.
This was a little 52-meter house,
feet.
And we'd take non-skilled labor
and build them in the factory.
Okay.
- [Mark] All right.
- That went when Reagan was in,
they were going for
the,
the Contra missile people
when they had those
homes were developed for.
- [Mark] So do you have any support from
local governments or anything like that?
- No, we're we,
I bypass the local government right now
because the two or three times
that I have talked to them,
or the
couple
they got their money
all set aside
like the schools.
And that's why the buildings are costing
$400,000 to $600,000
a unit.
And these buildings that we're
building in the factory costs
only about 85,000.
Time you put them on the land
and do the site work,
you're probably 150,000.
So it's about half the price,
half the quality.
And these are also the solar-solar
solar powered.
- [Mark] Oh, they're solar?
- Yeah, they're solar.
So everything we've been doing
is what we're doing for here.
So that's the same quality.
We are also working on
building fire-resistant homes
and the fire-resistant homes
that we're gonna build,
gonna go out in Paradise.
And as you know, fire,
but it's a home that has no wood.
We have a product that we developed
that is UL approved.
Gives you a three-hour firewall.
Now like up in Paradise,
where they had the big fires,
We also make buildings
that would be where people can go in there
and lock theirself in
for 72 hours,
and let the fire burn by
and go from there.
- [Mark] So the home is
actually a protection.
- Yeah.
Now when we start doing this,
we're gonna open up three major factories
in LA County.
Okay, one factory will
be to build the kit.
We call them kit.
The next one will be building
the equipment to build the panels.
And then the next one will be
the thermal shield
which actually is a
product that we developed
that you put on a building
and it gives you a three-hour firewall.
So that product but it also
not only gives you a three-hour firewall,
the other thing that it does
it actually drops the
temperature 35 40 degrees.
If a house is in the coal area,
it keeps it warm.
If it's in a hot area, it keeps it cool.
But it's a product that
we used on the school.
It's DSA approved and it's UL approved.
Okay, it's a product that we develop.
So that's what we're up to.
But then this building business,
I've been doing this product
since
1980,
we had some good runs
with big companies like Morrison, Knutson
and companies like that, that
we did in the Philippines
and different other countries
that we did things for.
But we've been doing this forever.
Our background was concrete.
We know more about concrete than anybody.
I started building
everything from Oroville dam,
to missile silos and in
Santa Maria
up there humpback.
So we've been in the concrete business.
We did Bart in the Bay area.
We did a lot of work at the LA airport
and all the parking structures.
And we did dams.
We did three dams.
They were supposed to
build 23 dams in the state.
We did three of them,
and then they ran out of money.
But we came down with
the federal river project
Orville all the way to San Diego
doing different parts of the project.
So our background was concrete.
When I was in Africa,
I tried to build concrete home.
Thought, well I'm in
the concrete business,
I should be able to build concrete home.
It seems like it works.
You end up with a box,
but the costs and the labor
and the amount of equipment you need
makes it not feasible.
Okay, so what we're doing now,
the three plants that
we're setting up here
in LA,
they will partake this
and then we are gonna take it to
four sites
in LA or LA County.
And the site will have a school
have the thing to train the people
how to put them back together.
And then also the job site
we're gonna need anywhere from
2-4,000 people
to,
to start this project
- [Mark] Having employment for a lot
of these people would change the lives.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And then they would,
this would be ongoing
employment for them, or--?
- We're gonna, oh yeah.
They'll be, because when
we get them trained,
we'll be doing work in Paradise.
And what we're gonna
do is put what we call
them a satellite plant.
So we're gonna take the same thing,
put it up there.
And the people that we're training here,
will go there
and,
and work
up there in that job,
the company that's putting in the money
wants us to have 10,000 people to work.
So,
as you know,
I'm getting calls from
San Jose,
San Francisco, we're talking
to some people in Washington.
We know we got a deal in Texas.
And in Florida.
- [Mark] So this would
potentially be a new location
for the homeless
communities in these cities?
- Oh, yeah.
Now, these are,
go back and look at the homeless,
and what is people don't,
they don't want anybody in their backyard.
But if you put them in a gated community,
a secured gated community,
and select the ones that
you're gonna put in there
under qualification,
okay,
we know that some of them
that need medical help
and different things,
but this is actually a home.
What we have to do is find
a way to bring some dignity
back into the homeless market.
Because right now,
all they're doing is
just taking the money,
putting it in their own pocket,
the big boys
and they're not doing
what they should be doing.
And one, they need jobs,
okay.
Number two, they need
a quality place to live
and then need education to be there.
- [Mark] No, I think just being employed.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Build self-esteem and-
- As the employment, we're
gonna pay $15 an hour
as they're in school for eight weeks.
We're gonna pay them $15 an hour
when they come out of school.
It's gonna go from 20 to $27 an hour.
Okay,
this whole project,
and we got it all on paper,
it's all penciled out.
We know exactly how much
money we need to spend
and how much we gotta put in.
- [Mark] Oka, are you looking
for help from anybody, or--
- Yeah, we're gonna be looking for
non-profit organizations to manage these.
And that's where Ida comes in.
She's gonna be setting up
the peoples, the nonprofits--
- [Mark] Ida's your marketing director?
- As marketing director, yes.
And so that's what we're doing.
She's marketing director for that.
And also for the fire-resistant homes.
CHS has been in business since 1959,
building roads, freeways,
water projects, dams.
We had the patents
on the center divider for the freeways
and the big papers.
I had something to do with
every freeway out here in California.
In 1960,
there was nothing out here at all.
So we did concrete
was our background and back in those days.
And so, but the reason
I got into this housing
the way we're doing it,
is that every time I would
go to these other countries
like Brazil and
Argentina,
and that the first thing
they would ask you,
do you have houses?
We're also working on
farming communities for other countries.
I got one farming community
we're working on now
that they're supposed to be funding
and that's in Laos.
And that's a seven square mile
farming community to start.
So that package is all
together, and then we--
- [Mark] You're building housing there?
- Huh?
- Would be houses, buildings.
They wanna raise
5,000 cattle
a year
for the market.
But it's everything from
dairies to farming to roads.
It's just raw land right now.
And we laid it all out.
But that's what we're doing on that.
Also, we have a gentleman
as one of our funding sources,
wants to do it in Africa.
Cause they're talking about Africa,
having not enough food
to feed their people.
So we're trying to take
things that need to be done and do it.
Now that package is completely done
and we know the cost,
we know what we're doing.
And how the one in Laos,
it started all the way from road
to you name it.
All it is is just raw land.
And going from there in Laos.
So that's where we are.
- [Mark] That sounds great.
- So we got other countries
that we're talking to, to do that.
So that--
- [Mark] So once you get
the funding you need,
you'd be off and running?
- Yeah, it's all--
- [Mark] You need some
land though, too, right?
- Yeah. No,
the people want, they want jobs.
It's all about jobs.
It's all about
training people we need.
- [Mark] I would think
there's some motivation
from the cities to fix
their homeless problem
and find the land somewhere, and,
- Yeah,
well here finding land,
the city and the county has a lot of land.
They got it in their
pocket for somebody else.
We gotta get to the point where we can be
upfront once we see what we're doing,
and that's where we're up to.
Where we can actually
employ people here in town.
Okay!
The money people are asking us
can we go to take this
thing up to New York?
Can we go to Florida
(clears throat)
where the
unemployed...
I mean the homeless is.
So this is a solution.
Okay!
Is there other solutions out there?
Probably is.
But,
after thinking about this whole thing
and you see the designs of the buildings
and you see the quality of the building,
these buildings are
guaranteed to last 150 years.
- [Mark] Yeah, and plus
you're putting the guys to work too.
- Yeah. It's all about job
It's all about taking
non-skilled labor and training them.
And the big problem they have
with jobs today for the homeless,
they work a week or two,
and then they're gone.
They work a week or two,
and they're gone.
Here, it's gonna be a long-term.
So that's what we're up to.
So you see why we have
a marketing director.
We have about 14 people,
engineers and everybody
working with the company,
people that run the plant and that.
But I did shut the plant down here
because the contracts for
the schools just ran out.
Or actually, they ran out of money.
They still need to buildings
but they ran out of money.
So that's where we are.
We're gonna be looking for people to
join with us and fund.
This time we have a nonprofit organization
we're setting up,
and we have a tax ID
number that we can actually
put this whole thing together.
Okay!
- [Mark] Excellent.
Well, Tony, thank you so much for
telling us about your project.
- So, that's where we're at.
- [Mark] That sounds great.
- Okay.
- [Mark] You know, you
basically have a nice solution
to the homeless problem.
- [Tony] Yeah.
Yeah, and it's not only a solution.
If we can provide
jobs of high quality or decent quality
and long-term jobs.
Okay!
And train the people in schools.
It's all about education.
It's all about training people
and putting,
and when the people
will go to work for it,
they have a way that they can move up.
They're just not locked into something
doing something the rest of their life.
They can actually move up with talent.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- [Tony] Okay.
- [Mark] All right,
Tony.Well, thank you so much.
- [Tony] So that's where we're at.
- [Mark] Awesome.
- [Tony] But thank you.
- [Mark] That's great.
- [Tony] Bye-bye.